[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
sur tv soixante dix huit pour cette
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction tout de suite les titres de ce
mardi 3 mars un rapport pour sauver la
culture et renforcer son accès à tous la
députée des yvelines
aurore bergé a remis récemment 60
propositions en ce sens au premier
ministre
interview avec la parlementaire qui nous
parlera de ses rencontres de terrain
notamment avec la barbacane aden et
juments 12 avant le premier tour des
élections municipales nous nous
intéressons notamment à la commune d'el
en cours ou trois candidats sont
déclarés reportage lors d'une réunion de
campagne du maire sortant jean michel
fourgous et michel rossi investi par la
république en marche sera elle notre
invité et puis le reste de l'actualité
de la campagne du scrutin avec la
présentation de la liste d'ismail havane
à maurepas focus aussi sur les candidats
à voisins le bretonneux avec l'épidémie
de coronavirus la tenue de ce rendez
vous sportif était menacé le paris nice
devrait finalement bien se tenir
est la ministre des sports roxana
maracineanu et maracineanu a
effectivement proposé est de maintenir
l'événement à l'issue d'une réunion
ministérielle qui s'est déroulée ce
matin maintien justifie car le tracé du
de la course au soleil ne passe pas par
des zones où le coded 19 a été détectée
est le départ de l'épreuve cycliste est
prévu pour rappel ce dimanche depuis
plaisir le lendemain la compétition doit
passer par chevreuse à l'organisateur à
esso a précisé par ailleurs que tout le
personnel présent sur le paris nice elle
devra impérativement ne pas provenir des
zones touchées par le virus
[Musique]
mais malgré le recours aux 49 3 la
réforme la mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites se poursuit ce
matin à elancourt une mobilisation s'est
tenue en présence des salariés de thales
crm à renault et airbus ils se sont
rassemblés dans la zone d'activités de
la clé saint-pierre elancourt plusieurs
revendications le retrait de la réforme
l'augmentation des salaires est contesté
aussi la suppression et des postes
annoncées chez airbus elle en cours
écoutez ses explications au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude thales est
aujourd'hui c'est une pompe à bille est
énorme
on a eu des chiffres d'ailleurs il ya
quelques jours la au niveau du groupe
tout le monde est content sauf nous
voilà dans la convention nationale
collective de la métallurgie est en
cours de renégociation et là on
on constate des baisses du socle social
énorme aujourd'hui
le patronat et ses 2
de mettre dans la convention sera payé
au poste aujourd'hui vous êtes ingénieur
vous gagnerez
x euros par mois eh bien demain vous
serez peut-être plus ingénieurs vont
vous donnera un autre poste
de petites ingénieurs on va appeler ça
comme ça et vous gagnerez moyen 60
propositions pour renforcer favoriser
l'accès à la culture aurore bergé député
des yvelines a remis son rapport au
premier ministre me février pour son
travail la parlementaire s'est appuyé
sur des rencontres de terrain notamment
menées dans le département hors bergé
nous a reçus pour une interview dans sa
permanence de rambouillet mélanie poké
pour les moyens techniques pour un
ministère de la culture au service des
créateurs des arts et des droits humains
le nom du rapport remis le 17 février
dernier au premier ministre edouard
philippe
et vous en êtes à l'origine roar berger
bonjour bonjour le député de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines porte
parole de la république en marche ce
rapport de 60 recommandations a pour
objectif de renforcer à l'accès à la
culture et ce à chaque âge de la vie
pourquoi avoir travaillé sur ce sujet
alors le prémice n'a confié cette
mission de parlementaires parce que déjà
je suis membre de la commission des
affaires culturelles est très engagé sur
ces questions là depuis le début du
mandat
ensuite parce que l'idée c'était aussi
de réaliser une enquête de terrain pour
aller à la rencontre des acteurs
culturels sociaux culturels des
fédérations d'éducation populaire des
élus locaux pour voir concrètement ce
qui se passait sur les territoires pas
pour les dupliquer parce que les
territoires sont tous différents et pour
voir aussi comment le ministère de la
culture pouvait plutôt être à la fois
stratège vis-à-vis des grands
équipements culturels et être mieux en
accompagnement à la fois vers les
publics et vers les acteurs culturels
sont en tout 450 acteurs culturels dans
le 25 départements que vous avez
rencontrées oui mais c'était vraiment
une volonté d'aller sur tous les
territoires du plus rurales au plus
urbain évidemment aussi dans les
yvelines à saint quentin en yvelines au
théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à benne ou là
vous avez une configuration est
différente puisque c'est une structure
qui est soutenu par la municipalité
vous allez avoir à la fois du théâtre
mais aussi le cinéma évidemment aussi
passant catherine pégard qui préside le
château de versailles donc des acteurs
très différents même sur notre
territoire
alors ce sujet la culture pourquoi il ne
faut pas le mettre de côté pourquoi
l'accès à la culture et est primordiale
et ce à tout âge aussi à tout âge et dès
le plus jeune âge dès la toute petite
enfance tout simplement parce que
l'éveil aux arts l'éveil à la langue
française à la maîtrise du langage la
question de la place de la musique la
vocation de la place du livre dans votre
vie et bien tout simplement ça va
développer
on le sait bien que quand on a eu la
chance de le vivre chez nous des
facultés nouvelles des compétences
nouvelles
ça ouvre des cases en fait tout
simplement c'est aussi un facteur inouïe
de cohésion sociale dans une société on
le voit bien qu'ils aient parfois de
plus en plus fragmentée où on s'oppose
souvent les uns aux autres et bien la
culture est évidemment un facteur
formidable de lien puis pour les
territoires c'est aussi un facteur
d'attractivité de fierté sur les
territoires alors rentrons un petit peu
dans ce rapport pour voir quelques-unes
de vos recommandations
la première proposition elle vous a été
inspiré par sophie marinopoulos qui est
psychanalyste c'est de faire figurer la
santé culturelle dans le carnet de santé
des enfants est ce que cela impliquerait
davantage les parents dans l'éveil
culturel justement de leurs enfants
exactement c'est considérer qu'en vérité
l'éveil artistique et culturelle c'est
vraiment dès le plus jeune âge on le
sait aujourd'hui les 1000 premiers jours
de la vie de l'enfant sont déterminants
sur tout le parcours qu'il pourra avoir
donc évidemment ça concerne sa santé
physique mentale mais c'est aussi
évidemment ce qu'on a appelé santé
cultural sophie marinopoulos vous l'avez
dit qui a développé ce concept là ça
veut dire aussi qu'il faut former le
personnel de la toute petite enfance sur
c'est sur ces enjeux ça veut dire qu'il
faut renforcer la place des arts la
place des artistes dès le plus jeune âge
j'insiste beaucoup aussi sur la place du
livre lorsque je crois que là encore une
fois la maîtrise du langage est
déterminante et le lien on peut avoir
entre un enfant et un parent grâce au
livre ce que ça peut générer en termes
de parentalité est extrêmement important
d'ailleurs vous souhaitez voir la mise
en place de mal à lire dans des lieux de
la petite enfance exactement que ce soit
les pmi que soient les crèches c'est à
dire tous les lieux d'accueil de la
petite enfance il faut familiariser la
présence du livre il faudrait que le
livre entre dans toutes les familles
françaises
je crois que c'est probablement l'objet
culturel le plus essentiel qu'on puisse
avoir
et encore une fois dès le plus jeune âge
aussi parce que par rapport à la place
des écrans je pense que c'est
extrêmement pourtant de rester maîtres
de ce qu'on peut voir de ce qu'on peut
consulter et évidemment le livre nous en
prime une alors une autre proposition
forte qui est peut-être l'une des
propositions phares de ce rapport c'est
d'inscrire les droits culturels dans la
constitution
aussi inscrire la notion
de dire aux quatre savoirs fondamentaux
ces deux-là ajouté à ces quatre savoirs
fondamentaux je le rappelle c'est à lire
écrire compter et respecter autrui
ce serait une mesure forte pour donner
toutes ses lettres de noblesse à la
culture je le crois en tout cas c'est
pour ça que j'ai préconisé jean michel
blanquer a mis en place en effet ces
quatre savoirs fondamentaux à l'école et
je crois que dire c'est à dire la
l'oralité
je pense que c'est essentiel c'est une
faculté qui est pas toujours s'y
développer que ça on n'attend pas
forcément des élèves dans notre pays
ce développement mais je crois que c'est
essentiel et puis encore une fois là le
lien avec les oeuvres avec les artistes
la rencontre avec la musique avec le
théâtre évidemment on pourrait y
concourir largement et puis les droits
culturels
c'est un concept qui est extrêmement
important qui est de dire que en fait
chaque français évidemment est porteur
d'une culture et chaque français
d'ailleurs à une pratique culturelle
parce que dans notre vie quotidienne la
culture même si on le soupçonne pas
toujours elle est partie prenante de nos
vies et si l'idée c'est de reconnaître
la culture qui existe en chacun que
chacun porte la pratique culturelle de
chacun qui perd est en fait une porte
d'entrée pour ensuite développer une
culture commune parce que tout ça
l'enjeu c'est évidemment se dire est ce
qu'on peut avoir un terreau commun sur
lequel on peut tous appuyé est-ce qu'on
peut refaire société ensemble est
évidemment la culture et contribuer et
que va-t-il se passer à présent alors
edouard philippe a salué la qualité
l'originalité des propositions l'idée
maintenant c'est que ce rapport
nourrissent la réflexion notamment de la
feuille de route du ministère de la
culture bien sûr moi j'ai donc remis son
rapport au premier ministre
on en a longuement parlé l'idée c'est
que dès le mois d'avril
et puis y avoir des annonces du
gouvernement pour se saisir de mes
propositions et les mettre en oeuvre
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui
passent pas par la loi mais qui vont
passer tout simplement par le
gouvernement directement au pouvoir
réglementaire et donc je crois qu'il est
très déterminé
notamment sur tout ce qui concerne par
exemple livres pour le mettre en place
et le ministère est en train
profondément de se restructurer et de la
même manière d'idc évidemment que ces
propositions ne sert pas à calais une
porte mais bien au contraire que le
ministère puisse s'en saisir et que ce
soit mis en oeuvre
merci à aurore bergé merci à vous député
de la 10e circonscription des yvelines
porte parole de la république en marche
et je le rappelle vous êtes à l'origine
donc de ce rapport pour renforcer
l'accès à la culture et aurore bergé en
parlait pour
rédiger son rapport elle s'est servie
notamment de l'exemple de la barbacane à
ben l'établissement mène plusieurs
actions culturelles tout au long de
l'année notamment des représentations
théâtrales ouverte aux scolaires zoom
avec aurélie rose
la troupe de la pièce intra muros saluée
par les scolaires après une
représentation uniquement dédié à ce
public venu du centre yvelines ah ben le
théâtre la barbacane et géré par un
syndicat intercommunal sept communes
sont associées et travaillent ensemble
sur la programmation
la spécificité de ce bâtiment c'est
qu'il a été construit et ouvert il ya
une trentaine d'années avec l'idée que
tout le monde allait pouvoir se croiser
et une bibliothèque municipale un volet
associatif qui est porté par la ville de
ben avec différentes activités de la
pratique artistique
et puis dans notre salle de spectacle en
effet il ya spectacle mais aussi cinéma
plusieurs fois dans l'année les
représentations théâtrales sont suivis
de bord plateau un moyen de partager qui
permettent aux scolaires de se
familiariser avec le monde du spectacle
j'aime bien la transmettre un petit
savoir l'autre chose partager un peu
avec avec les jeunes parce que moi dans
mon parcours personnel j'ai souvent
rencontré des professeurs que ce soit de
sport de lettres de même de maths ou de
géographie qui m'ont souvent apporter
autre chose que leur matière en décembre
dernier l'établissement culturel a reçu
la visite d'horreur bergé la députée
yvelinois s'est inspiré de ce lieu pour
son rapport sur le développement de la
culture pour tous donc l'enjeu c'était
de parler de comment à l'échelle d'un
territoire
on arrive à créer des mutualisations des
convergences des circulations qui
viennent parfois jusqu'à notre lieu
théâtre mais parfois c'est le théâtre
qui va sur sur les villes
du syndicat un accompagnement à la
culture qui a également permis à la
barbacane de devenir le premier lieu des
yvelines à porter le label scène
conventionnée pour la musique et après
ce journal retrouvez comme chaque mardi
soir le 7-8 culture pour connaître les
prochaines sorties spectacles concerts
et expos à faire dans les yvelines
[Musique]
nj - 12 avant le premier tour des
élections municipales les électeurs ont
rendez vous aux urnes le 15 mars
prochain candidat en 2014 à maurepas
ismail havane est reparti en campagne
pour ce scrutin de 2020 une liste
fortement renouvelée qui l'a présenté en
fin de semaine dernière lors d'une
réunion publique
l occasion aussi de présenter plusieurs
points de son programme mélanie potier
et nouvelle gouvernance locale la mise
en place de la transition écologique
vivre dignement ce sont les grands axes
du programme 10 miles havane l'actuel
conseiller municipal d'opposition veut
notamment créer une commission de la
transition écologique piloté par le
premier adjoint
cette commission et sera ouverte par
tirage au sort aux habitants est aussi
ouverte aux habitants et habitantes
désireux de vouloir intégrer à cette
commission et nous avons la chance à
mort quoi d'avoir des citoyens experts
dans certain nombre de domaines ce sera
l'occasion aussi les impliquer une liste
presque entièrement renouvelé sept
colistiers repartent d'airial ismaïl à
vannes
nous avons souhaité vraiment un
renouvellement au niveau de notre liste
est impliqué des hommes et des femmes
qu'on parle l'habitude de la pratique de
la vie politique à l'échelle locale et
donc du coup nous avons réussi notre
pari puisque notre appel au
rassemblement a été vraiment entendu
parmi les nouveaux des fonctionnaires
des chefs de projets de jeunes
travailleurs à noël inspectrice dans
l'aide sociale pourrait se voir confier
les affaires sociales un projet social
et solidaire pour moi la solidarité
effective entre tous les citoyens
elle est très importante
les plus forts doivent aider les plus
faibles dans une commune c'est aussi le
rôle de la mairie et des élus mettre en
place un transport à disposition des
personnes qui en auraient besoin ça pour
se rendre à des rendez-vous médicaux
soit pour se rendre à des activités
prochaine réunion de la liste maurepas
dynamique et solidaire jeudi 5 mars à 20
heures au cesa de la jo en 2014 la liste
d'ismaïla vannes avait rassemblé 13 %
des suffrages dans la commune voisine à
elancourt trois candidats pour le poste
de maire on reçoit l'un d'entre eux sur
ce plateau michel rossi vont soir dans
ça vous est la tête de liste est longue
course et vous une liste citoyenne
ouverte qui a été investi par la
république en marche comment se déroule
votre campagne
à 12 jours de ce scrutin est ce qu'elle
se poursuit à elancourt cette campagne
absolument
alors déjà si vous le permettez je vais
dire quelques mots pour présenter les
personnes qui sont sur cette liste
donc sur 35 candidats nous avons plus
d'une trentaine de personnes qui sont
sans aucune appartenance politique
d'où l'appellation de liste citoyenne
même si en ce qui me concerne j'ai été
investi attente est de 10 par la
république en marge
nous ne sommes que quelques personnes à
relever de ce mouvement et donc il était
normal que nous respections la majorité
des membres de notre liste et leurs
tendances sans étiquette politique
d'ailleurs j'ai contre monsieur fau
booth a précisé qu'il avait lui-même
quelques personnes de la république en
marche sur sa liste madame perrotta ne
l'a pas fait mais je crois qu'elle a
également des personnes en marche sur sa
liste donc c'est une liste investie par
la république en marche comme c'est
inscrit actuellement sur votre écran
mais qui est bien citoyennes ouvertes
pluriel vous venez vous du monde
associatif
pourquoi vous vous lancez dans cette
campagne justement vous êtes lancée
puisque la campagne a déjà démarré
mais vous êtes lancés dans cette
campagne des municipales alors j'avais
également des responsabilités
associatives mais en fait je viens du
secteur privé j'ai fait toute ma
carrière dans le secteur privé dans les
ressources humaines
que ce soit dans la métallurgie un
grande distribution les assurances ou le
secteur bancaire et j'ai travaillé aussi
bien sur l'aspect formation
apprentissage que négociation sociale
développement des compétences ou gestion
de budget et donc du coup pourquoi vous
vouloir vous engager parce que depuis à
peu près un an je suis à la retraite et
je me rends compte que cette ville
devient malheureusement une ville
dortoir qu'il y a beaucoup d'atouts mais
qui ne sont pas mises en avant et ayant
effectivement l'esprit solidaire et
m'intéressant aux personnes j'ai choisi
avec d'autres de m'engager pour ma ville
et de mettre mon temps disponible à
disposition de cette ville j'ai juste
une pression sur ville-dortoir on sait
qu'elle en cours il ya quand même de
grands groupes installés
je pense à à thales à airbus pourquoi
vous parlez de ville dortoir fut
justement parce que la plupart des
personnes que vous interrogez quand vous
les rencontrez 10 bat je pars tôt le
matin tout le monde ne travaille pas sur
place malheureusement beaucoup viennent
d'ailleurs y compris d'ailleurs danser
dans ces grands groupes et donc par tôt
le matin reconnaît ses difficultés de
circulation et rentre tard le soir et le
week-end quand on est déjà bien occupé
dans la semaine on n'a pas le temps de
profiter de sa vie de mal aux jambes dit
est être allé à la rencontre des élans
courtois d'ailleurs je crois qu'avant de
constituer votre programme c'est depuis
octobre vous menez des rencontres auprès
des élans courtois pour recueillir des
deux bonnes idées afin de constituer ce
programme c'est insensé un programme co
construit suite à ces premiers échanges
nous avons commencé à nous rendre compte
des axes essentiels pour elancourt que
ce soit de redynamiser cette ville parce
que vraiment elle a perdu toute
attractivité elle perd régulièrement des
habitants depuis 2006 c'est également
une ville où il ya des instances et des
institutions culturelles sportives mais
qui ne sont pas ouvertes à tous et
accessible à tous notamment aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
donc il ya des choses à faire aussi sur
le plan culture et sport c'est une ville
je ne parlerai pas de la zone des 4
armée qui n'est pas très reluisante sur
ce sujet vous souhaitez voir un
écoquartier tout à fait absolument c'est
un de nos axes forts sur l'attractivité
est relancé
le dynamisme économique dans cette ville
donc nous avons pour cela appartement où
vous lancez un écoquartier vous pouvez
bénéficier de subventions donc ça ne
pénalisera absolument pas les impôts des
élans courtois ou bénéficier de
subventions à la fois gouvernementaux et
également de gouvernementales et de
subventions de la région également pour
construire cet écoquartier nous enfuir
on nous enfuir on les lignes électriques
et promesses de monsieur funds depuis
plus d'une dizaine d'années mais qui n'a
toujours pas été tenues mais ce qu'avant
de prendre ces décisions si vous êtes
élu est-ce qu'il y aura une consultation
des aimants courte on sait que c'est
l'un des trois axes de votre campagne d
aller vers plus de démocratie
participative
c'est à fond nous allons d'ailleurs dans
une de nos propositions je vous la livre
en avant-première nommer un adjoint à la
démocratie participative pour d'une part
quand il ya un projet fortement
impactant un quartier associer tous les
acteurs concernés donc nous travaillons
non seulement avec les habitants mais
également avec les commerçants je nous
souhaitons faire aussi une zone de
commerces qui bien entendu ne met pas en
concurrence les commerces déjà existants
donc nous aurons effectivement cette
concertation nous aurons également cet
adjoint qui prendra régulièrement
contact avec des référentes quartier
pour bien remonté tous les besoins des
quartiers et nous ouvrirons également un
service à la mairie qui s'appellera
relation citoyen alors le deuxième axe
redynamiser la ville vous en avez déjà
dit un mot il ya aussi une thématique
qui revient largement dans cette
campagne des municipales c'est
l'écologie et c'est le troisième axe
aussi de votre campagne qu'est ce que
vous prévoyez en termes d'affaires
d'écologie c'est un axe très fort dans
notre campagne
vous aurez la possibilité de valoriser
tout ce qui est espaces verts nous avons
un peu près 100 110 hectares d'espacés
verts dans cette commune
nous souhaitons non seulement bien sûr
les préserver il faut savoir que
monsieur voigt a installé un certain
nombre de logements le stade paul
nicholas on a d'ailleurs fait les frais
vous avez quand même inscrit à saint
quentin une construction de logements de
plus de 850 habitations je ne sais pas
où elles se trouveront mais cela pose
question et je crois savoir également
que france miniature dont le contrat
arrive à échéance en 2026 n'a pas eu de
garanties la prolongement de
prolongement de ce contrat donc si à la
base du stade paul nicholas vous avez vu
fleurir quelques maisons à la place de
france miniature vous pouvez vous
attendre à une environ 800 ou 900
logements
donc c'est pas du tout ce qu'on souhaite
nous on souhaite conserver france
miniature et développer un partenariat
justement avec les écoles pour
développer tout l'aspect histoire
géographique qui est tout à fait
possible avec ce parc est un autre
projet d'envergure je voudrais vous
entendre sur ce sujet l'aménagement de
la colline d'elancourt en vue de ces jo
de 2024 et ce qu'il faut repenser à
l'avenir de cette colline est ce que le
projet qui est prévu vous satisfait ce
que vous imaginez un autre futur pour
cette colline par déjà le projet prévu
j'aimerais qu'on le précise parce que
feue la piste de ski ça c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
l'idée d'un globe ou d'un restaurant
panoramique au sommet me semble
totalement surréaliste ça ne répond
absolument pas aux attentes des élans
courtois c'est totalement indépendant
d'en faire une zone olympique
donc nous nous sommes pour les jeux
olympiques puisque nous sommes pour
l'attractivité de notre territoire
mais cela veut dire des jeux olympiques
éco-responsable comme s'est engagé le
comité des jeux olympiques
et ça veut dire un aménagement famille
et au sommet auront éventuellement une
table d'orientation mais pas une
construction pérenne en dur merci michel
rossi je rappelle que vous êtes la tête
de liste des longs cours c'est vous et
je précise que sont également candidats
à elancourt catherine perron tard faste
avec réinventons elancourt et jean
michel fourgous avec aller elancourt le
maire sortant les républicains tenait
d'ailleurs sa première réunion de
campagne vendredi dernier dans la salle
du conseil municipal pour ce rendez vous
avec ses soutiens à l'élu a reçu la
visite de la présidente de la région
valérie pécresse reportage
c'est en un peu plus de deux semaines du
premier tour des municipales que jean
michel fourgous a réuni habitons et
soutien à l'hôtel de ville d'elancourt
le maire sortant se lance dans une
nouvelle campagne pour continuer de
porter ces projets dans la commune où il
est élu depuis 1996 une ville comme
elancourt ou ou
je suis comme depuis un certain temps
mes enfants sont nés ou où ils y ont
vécu et
le voir par exemple changer le système
éducatif
à partir d'une en course et c'est
passionnant demain le système peut-être
de sécurité un modèle qu'on est en train
de construire
je dirai quel emploi est une plate forme
je dirais d'innovation française
aujourd'hui c'est une ville à la
campagne c'est une ville assez calme en
fait protéger cette ville à la campagne
fait partie des dix priorités de la
liste à elancourt mener à bien aussi le
projet de commissariats d'agglomération
qui doit voir le jour dans la commune
étendre la police municipale au dimanche
ou encore développer un grand plan vélo
et mettre en place un budget
participatif pour cette réunion la
présidente de la région valérie pécresse
également engagé dans le scrutin dans
les yvelines est venu soutenir jean
michel fourgous on porte des fabuleux
projet pour l'avenir
le projet de la colline d'elancourt qui
va devenir la colline du vélo en
ile-de-france et en france ce sont des
magnifiques projets et je ne vous parle
pas évidemment de toute l'éducation
numérique que nous déployons lui dans
les collèges et les écoles et moi dans
les lycées de la case qui est des cibles
et l'éducation et le numérique sont
d'ailleurs toujours au coeur des grands
projets d'al elancourt parmi les
propositions ouvrir le lab pour
accompagner les usages numériques des
familles proposait des ateliers de
robotique et de programmation enfin
tester des innovations pour adapter la
pédagogie aux enfants touchés par le
handicap
enfin à voisins le bretonneux trois
candidats ont déposé leurs listes la
maire sortante alexandra rosetti aura
face à elle béatrice pirae olivier à
fond saut présentation de ses candidats
avec manon varaldo à voisins le
bretonneux trois candidats s'opposent
pour devenir le maire de cette commune
de 11 1426 habitants la maire sortante
alexandra rosetti habitante de
voisins-le-bretonneux depuis 1998 ancien
professeur d'anglais se représente
parmi ces projets la construction de
l'écoquartier de la remise ou encore une
salle des fêtes
c'est celui d'avoir une
une salle des fêtes un lieu dédié où les
gens puissent faire célébrer leur
mariage leur anniversaire puisque
aujourd'hui voisins beaucoup de salles
de quartier mais tout est enclavée dans
des résidences où il ya des habitations
autour donc on ne peut pas les loups et
parce que là ça fait du bruit tard la
nuit
donc on en est à prêter soit une école
nos associations soit notre petit
réfectoire de 50 places pour les
particuliers avec vos voisins avancé
mené par béatrice pire à une première
campagne pour la tête de liste salarié
dans l'industrie
béatrice pira et habitant au quartier du
lac depuis huit ans elle souhaite
notamment développer les mobilités
douces et créer une assemblée vie
sinoise voisins le bretonneux va avoir
dans les prochaines années des défis
stratégiques importants comme l'arrivée
de la ligne 18 du grand paris et nous
pensons qu'il est nécessaire d'avoir
quelque chose en plus dans notre ville
pour réfléchir sur ses décisions
stratégiques très impactante et nous
avons imaginé ce concept d'assemblée
vestine oise enfin olivier afonso tête
de liste unie pour voisin habitant de la
commune depuis dix ans ce conseiller
municipal depuis 2015 est responsable de
contrôle interne et qualité dans un
groupe de télécommunications le candidat
souhaite notamment créer un pôle santé
et social au thillay lé je voudrais
regrouper donc les médecins le
laboratoire
dans cette nouvelle structure moderne je
souhaiterais pouvoir mettre aussi le
ccas qui a besoin aussi de structures
d'accueil
peut-être avec un peu plus de
confidentialité pour les usagers à
l'actualité des élections municipales à
retrouver également dans le 7-8
politique émission chaque mardi soir sur
tv soixante dix huit présentée par
wilfrid richy c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité belle soirée à
tous sur tv 78
[Musique]